[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el mercado común
del sur el mercosur se enfrenta a uno de
sus momentos de tensión de mayor tensión
entre sus miembros después de que
uruguay que es uno de los países
integrantes anunció que avanza con un
acuerdo bilateral para alcanzar un
tratado de libre comercio con china
cuando uno de los compromisos de este
bloque es que este tipo de acuerdos
deben ser negociados y aprobados dentro
del bloque es decir entre los cuatro
países integrantes que son argentina
brasil paraguay y uruguay la negativa de
argentina en torno a este tipo de
acuerdos vuelve a poner en la mesa del
debate la necesidad de reformar las
dinámicas de este bloque más acorde a la
realidad comercial actual para que no se
convierta en un lastre tal y como lo
dijo en su momento el presidente
uruguayo luis lacalle durante su primera
cumbre del mercosur el pasado mes de
marzo el comentario por supuesto generó
reacciones al otro lado del río de la
plata en argentina escuchemos
obviamente que el mercosur su actividad
su producción
pesar el concierto internacional lo que
no debe ser y no puede ser es un lastre
nosotros no estamos dispuestos a que sea
un corset en el cual nuestro país no se
pueda mover no queremos hacer lastres de
nadie si usamos un lastre que tome
nuestro barco pero lastre no somos de
nadie
brasil bajo el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro respalda la idea de uruguay y
también entiende en cierta forma la
necesidad que tiene este país de abrirse
al mundo pero qué tan preparada hasta la
república oriental en cuanto a su
infraestructura para poder competir en
este mercado tan grande como lo es china
que dicen los empresarios que dicen los
sindicatos que dice la sociedad uruguaya
demos un vistazo también algunos de los
números para conocer qué tan cercana o
qué tan estrecha la relación que hay
entre la república oriental y el gigante
asiático china veamos algunas de las
cifras presentadas precisamente por las
autoridades uruguayas china es desde el
año 2013 el principal destino de las
exportaciones uruguayas en los primeros
ocho meses del año 2021 las
exportaciones del al país asiático ya
alcanzaron los 1.568 millones de dólares
eso significa un 63 por ciento más que
el mismo período en el año 2020 la carne
bovina uruguaya que ustedes ya la
conocen es un producto exquisito es el
principal producto de exportación china
dicho producto ha tenido también un
repunte en las exportaciones
internacionales no solamente a chinas
sino también a otros destinos como
europa es oportuno de dar un vistazo en
este momento en las relaciones al
interior del mercosur cómo está el
bloque en este momento como uruguay un
país de 3.5 millones de habitantes se
pondrá muy bien los pantalones muy bien
puestos para negociar un acuerdo gana
gana con la potencia comercial a nivel
mundial y también la segunda economía
más importante del planeta con un
mercado inmenso el tlc de la discordia
entre china y uruguay es nuestro tema de
debate en france 24 y para profundizar
en este tema saludamos a andrés ratio él
es coordinador de la sección en uruguay
de la asociación latinoamericana de
estudios asia y áfrica él se encuentra
en la ciudad de san josé en costa rica
también está con nosotros ignacio
bartesaghi director del instituto de
negocios internacionales de la
universidad católica de uruguay un
doctor en relaciones internacionales él
se conecta en esta oportunidad desde la
ciudad de nueva york en estados unidos y
aquí conmigo en el estudio de france 24
en la ciudad de bogotá está la doctora
angélica guerra varón ella es abogada
magister en el derecho internacional
amigo también es secretaria del capítulo
colombiano de la al lado les recuerdo
que ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con sus comentarios todas sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales estamos
en facebook en instagram también en
twitter síganos como france24 bajo ese
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 ya tenemos el
contexto tenemos los invitados pues
podemos comenzar y comienzo a canela
estudiar france24 con
angélica aquí que me acompaña aquí en el
estudio angélica y quiero comenzar por
preguntarle por uruguay y las leyes que
puede tener el mercosur está uruguay
pasando por encima de las leyes del
bloque del mercosur bien primero gracias
por la invitación en cuanto a tu
pregunta no podremos pensar o afirmar
que uruguay está pasando por encima de
las leyes lo que hay que tener en cuenta
es que es el mercosur el mercosur es un
esquema regional donde ha habido un
esfuerzo de parte de los países miembros
de conformar
y esquema de integración mucho más
avanzado si bien es cierto no se trata
de un esquema supranacional es decir
donde hay una ley superior que emana del
consenso mismo de los estados miembros
si podemos señalar que la intención o el
espíritu que movió la creación del
mercosur fue precisamente actuar en
bloque actuar como una sola unidad como
una unidad como un grupo como un
colectivo en el momento en que uno de
los países se les ocurre que podrían
llegar a suscribir un acuerdo fuera de
el esquema que existe dentro del
mercosur no necesariamente está yendo en
contra de yo creo que esa es una manera
de ver las cosas desde una perspectiva
más jurídica pero también podríamos
verlo desde la perspectiva del derecho
internacional económico y en ese sentido
es un poco sentar las bases para que
haya un marco de entendimiento y para
poder arreglar las
las dinámicas del mercado que se dan
entre china y uruguay más allá porque tú
bien lo ha señalado como sea la relación
entre estos dos países también sería
posible hacer una mirada desde la desde
lo político y en lo político las
palabras de los presidentes y todo este
asunto que emergió como tú bien das
señalaste en la introducción si daría
pie para pensar muchísimas más cosas al
respecto que en la ciudad de san josé
costa rica andrés le doy la palabra para
que nos ponga en contexto y complemente
lo que ha dicho angélica si es necesario
uruguay está pasando por las leyes está
pasando por encima las leyes del
mercosur el mercosur está volviendo así
una camisa de fuerza para los cuatro
países que lo integran de forma
permanente
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
primero que nada
claramente hay un análisis que es
político que va mucho más allá de los
jurídicos esto nos recuerda una frase
muy famosa de josé mujica justamente el
entorno de la cumbre de mendoza en 2012
sin equívocos que decía que los
jurídicos lo político está por encima de
los jurídicos independientemente de
cualquier análisis comercial y de
beneficios y perjuicios que pueda tener
las firmas eventuales un tlc aquí a mí
lo que me gusta agregar es una una
tercera dimensión que ya no es ahora el
bilateral o el internacional digamos que
se puede pensar en términos generales en
las relaciones internacionales sino
también una mirada intermedia que en
este caso es la regional que la que
estaba planteando esté muy bien la
colega en este marco en particular el
uruguay tiene sobre sus espaldas la
responsabilidad de llevar a por encima
las fronteras posibilidades en a nivel
político y no jurídico en el rever
algunas normas que han han regido hasta
el día de hoy en el uruguay perdón en el
mercosur y que en uruguay hasta ahora si
bien venía presentando su disconformidad
en diferentes gobiernos en el siglo 21
no había generado esta instancia de
la eventual negociación que es este
estudio de factibilidad que se está ya
se está empezando a trabajar y que
evidentemente genera una respuesta y
grava a tener seguramente por lado de
los países vecinos porque
independientemente de que se pueda decir
que esa famosa cláusula 3200 es la
vigente o no las circunstancias las
consecuencias que pueden traer para el
país también tienen que estar
consideradas del punto de vista político
decir no más allá de lo jurídico en este
caso me da la sensación que por encima
de eso por encima incluso de lo
comercial está lo político por supuesto
que esto también tiene consecuencias
comerciales como beneficios que podría
tener de que se entonces el punto
central aquí es hasta dónde va la
estrategia del uruguay y hasta donde
están previstas las diferentes
perspectivas que pueda tener ante
escenarios que ciertamente son muy
complicados y no olvidemos el tamaño
relativo en nuestro país del uruguay es
un país exageradamente pequeño en
relación a brasil y argentina- y
exageradamente pequeños a china claro
ignacio partes aquí se une a esta
conversación desde la ciudad de nueva
york en eeuu sus impresiones sobre la
posición que tiene uruguay que tiene
esta necesidad lo ha dicho el presidente
debe abrirse al mundo pero se está
abriendo con el mercado más gigantesco
que existe en el mundo con la potencia
comercial del planeta y lo está haciendo
causando un poco de incomodidad
digámoslo así a sus vecinos más cercanos
como el de santiago gusto saludarte
también angélica y andrew gracias por la
invitación
lo primero que había que decir es porque
estamos discutiendo esto santiago no
estamos discutiendo esto porque el
mercosur no ha logrado abrirse al mundo
en 30 años de historia porque es
relevante el tema porque necesitamos
acceder a más mercados para poder
exportar más productos y más servicios y
eso se hace desde la década del 90 en
adelante a través de la firma del
tratado de libre comercio entonces lo
primero que tenemos que decirle a
angélica lo planteaba es que si bien es
cierto que el bloque ha puesto a sus en
sus orígenes a conformar una unión
aduanera de un mercado común a que todos
juntos íbamos a negociar la historia nos
demuestra que nunca alcanzamos los
objetivos planteados en el año 91
entonces la discusión no es sólo es
uruguay cumple o no con el acuerdo con
los tratados con como decía andrés con
la 32 doble cero la discusión pasa a ser
política económica pasa porque porque no
podemos seguir esperando que argentina
se decida a abrir entonces el debate
ha sido muy fuerte y nos ha puesto
brasil y uruguay de cierta forma contra
argentina porque a la vez el mercosur se
está dando cuenta que si no reacciona a
las tendencias internacionales
corre un riesgo de quiebre y lo que ha
pasado acá a diferencia lo que ha
ocurrido en otras ocasiones
es que ahora es brasil principalmente a
través de su ministro de economía y del
presidente bolsonaro el que quiere un
cambio el que impone un cambio en el
mercosur y el que dice yo necesito
abrirme al mundo y lo hace de dos formas
santiago lo hace proponiendo bajarla a
hacer esta no común la hacen del bloque
que es bueno recordarle a la audiencia
que es el doble de la media
internacional
pero también lo hace apoyando a brasil a
brasil perdón apoyando uruguay de
abrirse al mundo nada más y nada menos
como vos decís con la segunda economía a
nivel mundial y en dos años va a ser la
primera no entonces eso diría que es el
contexto donde dónde dónde debemos
partir más es algo jurídico y lo
político bien hago la ronda a la inversa
sigo con ignacio y me voy a entonces a
ese escenario que usted describe ignacio
la necesidad que tiene el mercosur de
abrirse entonces qué fue lo que falló en
el mercosur que no pudo evolucionar a lo
largo de estos años para mantenerse
dentro de las necesidades comerciales a
nivel mundial y dentro de las
necesidades comerciales de los países
además que tengamos en cuenta usted lo
decían también hay unas diferencias de
las proporciones de las economías de los
integrantes abismales brasil es
gigantesco al lado de uruguay o paraguay
que entre otras cosas también están
negociando un tlc con chile que también
muestra ahí otro agujero que puede estar
abriéndose un poco más al norte del
uruguay que piensa usted
bueno yo te diría que hay que remontarse
a la década del 80 antes de firmar el
mercosur para darse cuenta santiago de
que siempre fue un bloque muy focalizado
ente argentina y brasil- el mercosur fue
desde sus orígenes un acuerdo más bien
sectorial que después se amplió en la
década del 90 pero que siempre tuvo un
enfoque muy marcado de bilateralismo
entre argentina y brasil entonces esas
economías
estaban firmando el 26 de marzo de 1991
algo en que el que no creían realmente
porque sabían que no iban a poder
abrirse en la dimensión que así se
planteaba entonces desde sus orígenes
por más que los primeros años del
mercosur fueron de cierto éxito el
bloque y se abrió con la región logró
cerrar acuerdos con la región ya
comenzaron rápidamente por un proceso de
politización que se dio muy fuerte
diría que después del
2000 en adelante
perdió esa posibilidad de abrirse al
mundo al ritmo que se estaban abriendo
las otras economías
entonces se diría que la razón por la
cual no nos hemos abierto a tiempo no
logramos abrirnos al mundo en los
tiempos que el mundo nos exigía es
definitivamente porque brasil y
argentina- no quisieron son economías
cerradas que tienen comercio entre ellos
muy fuerte tienen sus mercados internos
muy grandes entonces no están no estaban
preparados para abrirse al mundo
andrés están josé su opinión sobre que
falló en el mercosur que se está
quedando un poco atrás con las
exigencias
de hoy en día
bueno independientemente que sea un
proceso de integración regional centrado
originalmente en el comercio también el
mercosur se ha resignificado en un
bloque que va mucho más allá del
comercio de todas maneras me parece que
la respuesta digamos que puede abrir un
camino para el análisis tiene que ver
con las posibilidades reales y efectivas
de hallar un acuerdo de libre comercio
en particular a nivel bilateral y
eventualmente a nivel regional a nivel
regional si ese camino se abre no habría
ningún inconveniente ahí podríamos
hablar estrictamente de comercio y
eventualmente de los diferentes actores
nacionales que pueden estar a favor y en
contra decisiones puede compensar o no y
en particular también la actual
discusión de los capítulos pero en
concreto aquí hay un problema es lo que
plantea justamente ignacio el acuerdo
que existe hoy por hoy entre lo que
también podemos llamar esa diplomacia
presidencial que se está hablando mucho
al día de hoy entre brasil y uruguay
está condicionada por las elecciones en
brasil el año que viene
que da las encuestas- pareciera ser
revolucionarios no va a ganar esas
predicciones por otro lado también
argentina manifestado en un primer
momento el ministro de producción que su
lugar firmaba ese acuerdo tenía todo
derecho a hacerlo pero tenía que salir
del mercosur por no cumplir con la
cláusula y más adelante también este
algunos ministros han manifestado de que
uruguay
evidentemente si ya un acuerdo de ese
estilo china pero no es un difícil que
es un acuerdo de ese estilo porque china
no se comprometería la relación con
otros socios como es el caso argentina
que podríamos decir que se decía algo
así como más importante entonces éste
por eso me quiero centrar en la beta
política más allá de lo que espacio nos
parece sin embargo sur evidentemente los
objetivos no se cumplieron el uruguay se
vio en gran medida perjudicados del
punto de vista comercial y evidentemente
esa necesidad abrirse al mundo está
presente en los sectores pujantes de la
economía no obstante la viabilidad real
de ese tratado es que es muy difícil de
pensar en la medida en que uruguay es
difícil que se piense fuera del mercosur
pero no sólo porque se salga y nada más
sino por todas las consecuencias que
puede tener también con los socios más
importantes y una cosa también que tiene
que ver con cuánto pesa también la
economía
y visa darse algunas cosas más
importantes que tenemos todos sientes
que el empleo son los factores más
importantes se considera la economía por
otro lado es uno de los países que más
compra valor agregado es brasil entonces
nosotros tenemos una situación de
dependencia no sólo con china existencia
real
también la brasil y por supuesto la
gente
angélica aquí en el estudio de france24
quiero ir un poco más al contexto
internacional
actualmente cómo se está haciendo el
comercio internacional seguimos con esta
tendencia de hacer tlc es con todos los
mercados se están haciendo tlc es más en
contextos de unión de los países para
poder negociar en bloque con otros
países lo que vemos el de las alianzas
internacionales y de la diplomacia
internacional es que los países están un
poco más
cerrando ellos mismos lo vemos con eeuu
con el cambio política que ha venido
teniendo desde el gobierno trump a nivel
comercial entonces como se puede ver a
nivel internacional la tendencia si a
nivel internacional y me gustaría un
poco referirme más a la región a
latinoamérica es evidente que podría
hablarse de una suerte de crisis en
términos de la integración misma del
concepto de integración obviamente desde
una perspectiva política es mucho más
evidente darnos cuenta de esto desde la
perspectiva comercial más internacional
habría que señalar que hay una tendencia
desde los años noventas como bien
señalan nuestros panelistas de hoy que
se da o que procura la bilateralización
de las relaciones económicas a través de
los tratados de libre comercio o también
a través de instrumentos como los
acuerdos para la promoción y la
protección recíproca de las inversiones
y me estoy refiriendo a la inversión
extranjera
claramente nosotros como somos vecinos
de estados unidos de norteamérica las
dinámicas que se han dado en el norte
han necesariamente afectado las lógicas
política y mucho de las decisiones que
toman los valga la redundancia los
tomadores de decisión de nuestros países
si en medio de todo esto hay algo que a
mí me llama mucho la atención de
escuchar el debate tan interesante que
tú has planteado y tiene que ver con la
postura de uruguay con respecto a la
región hablemos de mercosur y también
hablemos de la postura de uruguay con
respecto al mundo es interesante y te lo
digo porque la política comercial
uruguaya tiene un enfoque
hacia lo internacional es un enfoque
aperturista claro es un país miembro del
mercosur pero tampoco olvidemos que hace
uno muchos años uruguay estuvo muy
pendiente de ingresar a otros esquemas
como es la alianza del pacífico
entonces fíjense cómo podemos darnos
cuenta de estos dilemas en los cuales se
encuentran los países y hablemos de los
gobiernos donde ellos tienen que
plantearse en su escenario cómo van a
tomar las decisiones desde la
perspectiva política y económica porque
definitivamente no se pueden separar es
lo que podemos señalar si es que todo lo
que tiene que ver con la integración y
desde la su vida política está un poco
en
standby por qué es esto por qué
muchas de las decisiones que finalmente
se tomen van a ejercer o van a llegar a
unos efectos negativos que muchos de los
diferentes actores que están
involucrados en ellas están muy atentos
soy por supuesto si nosotros estamos
hablando de la forma como los estados se
relacionan en sus dinámicas económicas
internacionales no debemos perder de
vista los actores privados seguramente
si uno hace un análisis mucho más
juicioso de lo que pasa en uruguay vamos
a darnos cuenta que
los que los grandes productores de
cárnicos o de soya o de la pulpa que son
los productos estrella que exporta
uruguay van a sentirse muy muy felices y
sólo para terminar un comentario que
puede ser interesante y es que el
planteamiento de hacer uruguay y su
sector productivo frente al gran reto
que se viene una vez este tlc entre en
vigencia yo esa pregunta se la voy a
trasladar a nuestros invitados uruguayos
y comienzo preguntándole andrés primero
que tan par es preparado está uruguay
para afrontar este de medirse a un tlc
con con china en cuanto a
infraestructura para los que no estamos
allí en uruguay y pues no sabemos en
detalle bien cómo está este tema y
pongamos en contexto y yo le trasladó
esa pregunta que usted hacía angélica
sobre cómo están las empresas los
sindicatos al interior de uruguay con
esta noticia se la trasladó a ignacio
pero dejemos que sea primero entonces el
que responda
bien me voy a tentar y voy a responder
todas voy a intentar mantenerme en la
estructura de tenencia entera puede
abarcar varios temas se lo agradezco ok
en términos generales en uruguay no es
un país si bien esa visión que se
marcaba de un país aperturista no está
no tiene el mismo músculo que pueden
tener otros países que han tomado una
iniciativa del bilateralismo de tlc es
como puede ser chile o costa arriba sin
embargo en el uruguay existe gente
formada que puede negociar perfectamente
con estos acuerdos de todas maneras este
tal vez lo relevante aquí sea cuáles son
los capítulos que ingresan en esa
estructura de negociación en esa posible
negociación y al mismo tiempo y otra vez
y perdón que sea reiterativo también hay
que saber así como los analizando en la
teoría de juegos qué pasa con los demás
actores y cómo presionan en ese mismo
proceso de negociación qué actores
además por supuesto van a perder y que
van a ganar pero que están dispuestos a
ceder a aquellos que van a perder qué
compensaciones se van a dar por último
digamos en cuanto a los actores que es
una parte que me interesa mucho hay una
tal vez y se puede decir una política de
estado respecto a esta idea de acercarse
más a china que primero fue comercial y
después fue política y ahora por lo
político y con otro gobierno con otra de
otro partido político también tiene la
intención de avanzar en un tlc pero sin
embargo vemos que la mayoría de los
actores dentro del país están en
términos generales de acuerdo la mayoría
de los partidos de la coalición de la
oposición e incluso por supuesto las
cámaras empresariales sin embargo existe
una una letra chica es siempre y cuando
sea con el mercosur para muchos de esos
casos por lo cual aquí lo que hay que
considerar es cuando un tlc se firma
también se tiene que garantizar que
cuando pase por el parlamento se apruebe
el pse incluso la mayoría están
planteando que tiene que sacar el
mercosur ese es un problema es decir
muchas bolas haciendo malabares que el
presidente y el gobierno va a tener que
manejar tanto adentro a nivel regional
como a nivel internacional con chip
claro ignacio continuó con usted para
que nos cuente cómo han recibido esta
noticia y este anuncio el empresariado
uruguayo los sindicatos como están allí
con esta noticia
en términos generales yo diría que la
noticia fue tomada con mucha
receptividad a santiago en el sentido de
que si bien hay algunas voces críticas
en términos generales en uruguay están
todos convencidos de que debemos
abrirnos al mundo y que china es un país
con el cual como decía andrés se viene
trabajando hace tiempo yo introduciría
algún matiz a esto que decía andrés en
cuanto a que la mayoría quiere que sea a
través del mercosur yo creo que la
mayoría quiere que se firme un tlc con
china sin afectar mucho al mercosur pero
no que se deba cerrar obligatoriamente
con el mercosur esa la discusión que se
tiene que dar yo creo que han cambiado
mucho de vuelta a los contextos tanto
del lado chino como del lado de brasil y
que es posible que este acuerdo se
cierra rápidamente porque brasil lo está
apoyando y porque la política
internacional de china no es la misma
ahora que la que era hace cinco o diez
años por supuesto que estamos en una
política mucho más
agresiva en términos internacionales
pues no pueden dar el paso de que china
quiera avanzar bilateralmente cuando a
cuanto antes no lo quería hacer y otro
punto que me parece fundamental
es analizar los impactos intereses con
china más allá de lo que es en bien es
claro que van a ver cómo es y angélica
ganadores en la carne de los lácteos en
los alimentos procesados pueden haber
algunos perjudicados en algunas
industrias que hay que atender como
decía andrés pero esto hay que mirarlo
me parece en una perspectiva de más de
algo aliento no que es lo que va a
ocurrir en cuanto a la cooperación en
cuanto a las inversiones en cuanto una
agenda con china porque cerrar que un
país como uruguay tan pequeño se
reutilice con la segunda economía a
nivel mundial que pronto va a ser la
primera con un cooperante muy importante
hoy para uruguay con la capacidad de
invertir en uruguay y uruguay lo
necesita pero yo creo que es mucho más
que comercio lo que estamos hablando en
este momento con china entonces debemos
dimensionar apropiadamente esos impactos
de los cuales se hablan poco pero cierro
con esto
los sindicatos pueden mostrar algún
reparo pero hay espacio para negociar
con ellos las cámaras pueden mostrar
algún reparo pero hay espacio para
negociar con ellos porque china es muy
pragmática y santiago como te podrás
imaginar vos y la teleaudiencia china no
quiere acceder al mercado uruguay no le
interesa eso es un mercado demasiado
chico para china me interesa otra cosa
no claro los intereses los hemos visto
en otros países incluso más pequeños ya
sabemos la historia de montenegro la
deuda que ha adquirido con con china a
cambio de la construcción de
infraestructura vial que ha puesto en
aprietos a la economía de este país de
el sur de europa y que tiene pues en
jaque prácticamente su ingreso a la
unión europea por ese préstamo
millonario entre beijing y poco dicha le
pregunto andrés en en san jose el peso
político que tiene esto para el
presidente lacalle es una de las grandes
apuestas del gobierno del presidente de
lacalle pou de no ser aprobado que tanto
afectaría a esto
al gobierno del presidente actual
sin lugar a dudas es una de las
políticas más importantes probablemente
los últimos años porque cualquier tlc es
importante pero como decía ignacio es la
magnitud que tiene china en la
representación en el comercio tiene del
uruguay que además el comercio exterior
es muy importante la economía uruguaya
evidentemente sería un acuerdo que
trascendería muchísimo más del gobierno
de todas maneras en la cuestión de que
tengan muy clara que es en los tiempos
que se tienen que manejar
podría ser perfectamente que el gobierno
termine su mandato sino un acuerdo
inclusive manteniendo todas los demás
problemas o resueltos los demás
problemas en cuanto al mercosur aún así
podrían aprobarse a tiempo y que no pase
por el parlamento actual evidentemente
si las negociaciones van en buena forma
y aún así no se aprobó podría ser muy
positivo para el gobierno sin lugar a
dudas ciertamente se está centrando en
una de las políticas más importantes
no sólo a nivel externo sino también a
nivel local lo que va a implicar y ella
implica una importancia tanto de la
imagen de gobiernos como del presidente
por lo cual es sin lugar a dudas que sí
sin
peso político pasemos a la región
angélica la relación que está teniendo
américa latina con china cada vez más
pisadas de china a nuestro continente ya
desde hace muchos años es el principal
actor comercial eeuu definitivamente
dejó de serlo como es la presencia china
en nuestra región con este tipo de
acuerdos quiénes son sus aliados más
cercanos cómo están parados acá bueno
eso es una muy buena pregunta gracias
por plantear la yo creo que la presencia
china en un en algún momento y obvio que
acá son unos una velocidad distinta de
cada uno de los países latinoamericanos
en algún momento fue algo quizás visto
como positivo en otras latitudes como en
colombia algo un poco temeroso hay que
decirlo y en este momento actual habría
que señalar que hay que tener cierto
cuidado si se piensa en en donde está
concentrándose la inversión china
y mucho desde una perspectiva ya
nacional o local si tú quieres cuál va a
ser el peso y cuál va a ser las
consecuencias de que haya tal inversión
china tan tan grande o sea como todos
sabemos no va a ser un monto pequeño y
no es en sectores que sean poco
importantes de hecho la presencia china
es claramente estratégica es guiada por
una política doméstica que como bien han
señalado ha cambiado no es la misma ha
cambiado muy muy rápidamente en los
últimos años en ese sentido lo que hay
que pensar es qué tipo de política y no
sólo comercial sino más política
exterior con su connotación económica
internacional quieren adoptar los países
está pregunta deberían plantearse en los
tomadores de decisión y me estoy
refiriendo a los presidentes ya los
cancilleres y sus equipos de trabajo
obvio un poco con con los otros sectores
pero es cuál es la respuesta y qué es lo
que vamos a hacer países que tenemos una
biodiversidad
significativa o países como uruguay hay
que ha quedado bastante claro en este
programa cuáles son sus productos de
exportación clave cuál es la política
que internacionalmente va a adoptar en
términos de política exterior con un
país como china claramente los teles el
ese es no son para competir el uno con
el otro labor que cuéntame tú quién
podría competir si hemos visto cómo han
cambiado las dinámicas internacionales y
tú bien han señalado que eso es lo que
ha sucedido con eeuu angélica
precisamente le iba a preguntar por eeuu
esto puede traer repercusiones para la
región puede tener repercusiones para
para un país como uruguay
que puede que no sea un país
tan cercano con eeuu como pueden ser
mexico o pueden ser colombia pero pero
tiene una relación importante con
washington por supuesto yo creo que
cualquier acuerdo aproximación o buen
entendimiento ya se trate de acuerdos de
cooperación o cosas más sencillas con
china necesariamente van a tener la
mirada de eeuu es algo que nosotros no
podemos evitar porque ha sido a partir
la historia donde hemos visto esta
relación esta dependencia de unos países
más más que otros con respecto a eeuu
decir que por el tlc quizás habría
alguna consecuencia
significativa para uruguay yo no pienso
así yo pienso que quizás políticamente
sí puede haber unos roces con los otros
países miembros que hacen parte de
mercosur como ya se ha mostrado muy bien
en el programa pero no creo que vaya a
haber unas consecuencias
negativas va a ser un reto que sin duda
va a ser un reto y principalmente yo
pienso que el reto va a ser mucho para
aquellos que no están tan adeptos
o que no ven esta idea de que uruguay se
acerque a china y qué pasa entonces con
los otros países me creo que la palabra
que mejor resume ese tipo de relación es
la que dice el presidente lacalle que
tal vez este tlc genere incomodidad más
que una discrepancia tan profunda vamos
ya para la recta final del programa las
conclusiones comienzo con ignacio
rápidamente 30 segundos ignacio qué va a
suceder con este acuerdo de libre
comercio como lo a futuro un poco aquí
jugando a la bola de cristal con
expectativa de que el estudio de
factibilidad que se está haciendo ahora
que ya comenzó a realizarse santiago
termina antes de fin de año y la
expectativa de que a principios del año
2022 se sostenga el apoyo de brasil
argentina entienda que tienen que tiene
que flexibilizar el mercosur porque si
no se puede quebrar y a partir de ahí
pueden iniciar las negociaciones que la
experiencia regional por ejemplo la que
se tuvo con chile demuestran que
interese con china se puede cerrar en
cinco rondas aproximadamente en un año
así que esa es mi expectativa
expectativa andrés para usted
bueno mi expectativa es un poco observar
también como pueden ser adapten de
diferentes dimensiones que estaban
mencionando la local la regional y la
internacional también vincularon las
relaciones con eeuu y quiere uruguay
este tipo estrategias puede obtener en
las estrategias puedo obtener las
ganancias con justamente hablamos todos
unidos la importancia que puede
generarse el contrabalanceo claro y
angélica rápidamente quince segundos yo
pienso que es bastante probable que haya
un tlc firmado entre estos dos países y
nuevamente el reto es cómo hacer para
que no se generen consecuencias
negativas sino para el contrario que
uruguay identifique los actores y los
procesos para sacarle provecho a esto
que creo que es inminente pues a los
tres invitados de esta noche les
agradezco haber estado con nosotros aquí
en france 24 ustedes también por su
sintonía les recuerdo que estamos ahora
en el debate de lunes a jueves a las 7 y
20 hora de bogotá quito y lima y lima
gracias por su sintonía sigan con
france24
[Música]